born in germany she's a queen in ghana
10 years ago the villagers of rpu made
me their nana which means queen mother
in english it's sort of like the mother
of the tribe
it's one of the highest ranks in
traditional ghanaian society a political
office comparable to that of a cabinet
minister
bettina landcraft first came to ghana
over a decade ago
to the small village of apu a six-hour
drive from the country's capital akra
a trained nurse she came to work on a
christian aid project here
there's a steep drop behind you when you
drive around a particular bend in the
road the landscape opens up and you see
the lake
that was the first thing i saw
and when you stand on the mountain and
look down you also see the village
that was my first impression of our
people
the villagers live from farming and
fishing
bettina landcraft arrived in 2001 to
nurse the sick
at the time she had no idea that that
decision would change her life
and in this room we delivered the babies
we had some paracetamol a few band-aids
and some swabs but otherwise we just
muddled through
it was precisely this challenge and the
fascination of ghana that won
the villagers were so happy that i
decided to stay
and not just stay for a few days to get
an impression and then leave again
i think that was the most important
thing for them
it meant we were able to develop a
relationship from the start life
the role of queen was an honor bestowed
on her in part because of the practical
help she provides the villagers
in 2007 she founded the aid organization
madame fo ghana
madam fo is the ghanian word for friend
we need a lot of money a lot of money
so money
without funding bettina landcraft's
plans would remain dreams
emanuel stefansson and his team of aid
workers coordinate the projects for
which patina raises the cash
they first met in a pew
when i met her first time
i thought she is intelligent and
she she is very brave too
so we decided to work together
their first joint project was
constructing a well in a pew but that
was just the start
two years later bettina landgrafer was
named nana mother of the tribe
that changed her standing in the society
vip when we started the project we are
betina we are emmanuel but
as time comes on and they installed her
as a developing queen mother we started
calling her nana
yes
one of the reasons for bettina
landcraft's prestigious rank is her
ability to find sponsors in germany
their donations now provide basic
services in many areas of the ashanti
region
this village for instance now has public
the toilets are especially designed for
villages like this places that are off
the beaten track
it's not possible for a tanker to come
here and pump out the human waste at
regular intervals this way it can stay
here
these sanitary units are manufactured in
germany especially for regions like this
the composted waste can be used as
fertilizers
you can imagine the hygienic conditions
here there are about 250 villages if all
of them go into the bush every morning
and then it rains it gets spread all
over the village and that leads to
disease
the motor of this development program is
the german ghanaian aid organizat
the german partner provides the cash the
two directors in ghana organize the
projects
without german organization however it
might not work so well
i'm very impatient and i want to get
things done quickly
of course that doesn't always work here
but it's actually a very good character
trait because it enables you to get
things done
whereas other people might take their
time
but the fact is when somebody entrusts
us with money i have to see that it's
put to use soon and that the person who
donated the money sees a result as
quickly as possible
is on our way to see the district chief
in basome frejo
madame fogana coordinates its projects
with government programs
observing local courtesies is important
starting with the traditional greeting
okay
so what are they currently doing today
they're discussing the next stage in the
construction of the kindergarten in
danso village
the district chief appreciates the help
provided by madame fogana
but of course
at first when i heard of my madam for
ghana i thought he was a man
telling me honorable look who told me he
was a woman when i met her
i i just opened my mouth and said hey
then what man can do men to women who
can also do it
that's the reason why has been stood a
queen even he's working faster than even
the government himself
it's not unusual for aid organizations
to be quicker than governments in
getting things done
but having a government representative
publicly admitted is pretty rare that's
impressive
dunso is a small village in the ashanti
region
with support from adam fogana the
villagers are building this kindergarten
here
we negotiate with the villagers first
because it's their project
they submit a proposal to madame for
ghana
when we agree on what should happen we
call a meeting of the tribe and finally
decide when we will start the project
and who will be in charge
and when it's completed
the government supplies the teachers
or in the case of a hospital the nursing
staff
what is going on over here
the builders were trained by madame
fogana
that's good
it looks nice
which colors are we using yellow and red
we always paint the buildings brightly
and it's also important to show the
sponsors
we like to include the people who have
donated money in the painting
and below that comes madame for ghana so
it's clear which ngo built it
money money
in a pew and two neighboring villages
madame fogana provides school children
with a daily meal and medical services
this little boy for instance when you
look at his scalp you can see that he
has a skin infection it's the result of
unhygienic living conditions
means a lot to me partly because it was
introduced by the ghanaian government
their original intention was to persuade
more children to go to school by
offering them a school meal
but
generally don't eat breakfast
the children come to school hungry
the children often have to leave home
very early because they have a long walk
to school some more than an hour some
two hours they won't have had much
breakfast before leaving home at four in
the morning so when they arrive they're
really hungry and can't concentrate
during the day
all they can think about is their
evening meal so the school meals program
eases that situation
bettina landgraf had no intention of
finding love in ghana but it happened
anyway
ebenezer
is studying marketing me and bettina got
to know each other through madame for
ghana
um
have traveled from germany for the
queen's 10th anniversary celebrations
and to meet their daughter's fiancee
when you visit people in ghana you can't
just appear out of the blue and say hi i
came to see you
we first have to ask if we may enter the
property because it doesn't belong to us
even as a nana i simply can't go
wherever i want to
has
they begin with a traditional handshake
you take the plastic chairs
okay you can now sit down now that we're
all shaking hands
bettina will settle down a bit now that
she's engaged
she had various relationships in germany
but i had the feeling that this kind of
division in her life
having someone in germany and living her
life in ghana
it just couldn't work
for lunch there's fufu
cooked bananas and yam roots served with
a spicy sauce
but i really cherish how much we talk
it's maybe something you wouldn't expect
because we come from two completely
different universes as we say
i think it's great
in the ashanti culture people eat with
their fingers
has gotten used to it
and now she loves eating together out of
the same bowl
the questions will fall
for you to answer
as
a typical ashanti here i
advise her on so many things especially
about our cultures and also how to
relate to most of our people and also
how she has to go about the work that
she is doing here
this week bettina landcraft is
celebrating not only her 10th
anniversary as nana but also her
birthday
a party is being prepared down at the
lake
and the whole village is expected to
turn up
today bettina landcraft is torn between
two roles
that of a dignified queen and that of an
excited birthday girl
to you
today
her best friend alvira dusenberg has
come from germany to surprise her
she gets right into the spirit of things
have been close friends for 16 years
ever since they trained together as
pediatric nurses
but patina has changed a lot since she's
lived in ghana
elvira is somewhat perplexed by
bettina's role as nana
bettina's
in her heart bettina is bettina but she
has an entirely different position here
a completely different status
because she's a person who commands
respect here she adopts a very different
tone
and i don't feel so comfortable with
that
because i'm not familiar with that side
of her or the tone she uses to speak to
the workers to ensure that things get
done
it's late afternoon
some workers from the aid project are
trying to clear an area for the big
anniversary celebration
50 helpers from the local tribe who had
promised to give a hand have failed to
appear
i'm really cross because it's typical
people are simply not punctual they pay
no attention to the time
when they say we'll do it they mean
tomorrow morning
and it makes me furious because they
always rely on madame for ghana
the tribal chief is in for a reprimand
i'll give him a piece of my mind he
won't know what's hit him i just want to
strip off the chairman
is due to be inducted as paramount queen
tomorrow
that's a step higher in the hierarchy
but so far virtually no preparations
have been made
the sun is setting and still nothing has
been done
nobody knows where the sound system is
and there are no chairs with the guests
or decorations for the table of honor
but the villagers have a reputation of
doing everything at the last minute and
managing somehow
now it's morning in the palace of a pew
for everybody to know each other i want
everybody to mention his name and then
where he's coming from chief great chief
for this community i'll come once in a
while and look at them and i want us
to take these trees
representatives from the neighboring
villages receive mango trees as a symbol
of growth and prosperity
they're also a souvenir of the
celebrations
as mother of the tribe bettina landcraft
will have even more responsibility in
the future
when you've had an education and can
read and write when you've read books
and know something of the world you can
really give good advice here
even to people who are older and have a
lot more experience of life
the nurse from germany has earned great
respect here with her advice and counsel
i look different and was born somewhere
else and i have a different cultural
background
although i wouldn't say that now because
i've been here for 12 years i now
understand ghanaians better than germans
this attitude explains one of the
pediatric nurses favorite projects
the labor ward in dunkura
it's a separate wing of the public
hospital
fact is a
reason
the fact is there's tremendous need
patients who live far away in the bush
can't walk home
and if there are complications there is
simply no ward for them
they just give birth
and then have to go straight home
and in principle
gunny and women are traditionally cared
for by their relatives while they wait
to give birth
they often used to come to the clinic
too late
or leave it until the last minute
in this project come from ghana they
were trained here and most importantly
trained for their conditions here
there are lots of things in ghana that
you don't have in germany and vice versa
since the nana herself is a trained
nurse
the midwives really respect her
it
delivered just five
the families and the husbands don't
realize that there's a gigantic wound in
the belly they think the baby's out and
everything's fine they don't realize
that postnatal nursing is necessary
we can now prevent all the infections
that can occur after giving birth
because of unhygienic conditions
is also about boosting the women's
self-confidence
the clinic also provides education and
family planning so that the women and
their husbands can decide for themselves
how many children they want they now
have many choices which they didn't have
before
originally came to ghana to work for a
few weeks on a christian aid project
she's still a member of the lutheran
church but now feels drawn to buddhism
which shares many values with
christianity
i personally believe that jesus lived i
believe in jesus as a human being but i
also think he was a good buddhist
when i read the bible
i think that he realized buddhist values
completely
and villagers like this mixture
their christianity is blended with their
own traditional beliefs
and we pray when everything is completed
i wouldn't say that i identify with that
because as a buddhist i don't pray in
that way
but i think it's nice because it fosters
a sense of community
it's the morning of the great day in the
nana's palace
a good decade after being named queen
bettina landcraft will be proclaimed
paramount chief
that will give her the same status as
the other paramount chiefs of the region
some 35 villages are hoping that their
situation will improve through patina
lancafe's leadership and with sponsoring
from germany
after laya dama yamana
is a chief from the north
nana has been a role model
she has come to develop
ghana
and
in particular in my hometown
where i am the chief
she has put up a very nice clinic day
and
very soon i knew it will be turned to
fully fledged hospital
the procession heads towards the
ceremonial ground
amazingly everything's ready
overnight tents were erected and the
sound system installed
there's even a throne and chairs
some of the guests have traveled for
days to take part in this ceremony
and of course it begins with a
traditional handshaking
it's been a long week
the birthday the engagement the 10th
anniversary as nana and now the
induction as paramount queen this nurse
from germany has found a fulfilling life
in ghana
libations are poured to the tribal gods
and ancestors
and then they pray to the christian god
amen
reads her acceptance speech from an ipad
the paramount queen
does live in two worlds
has achieved many things for the people
here in the heart of ghana
but their expectations remain high
as paramount queen she won't be able to
fulfill all of them
but with the help of her adopted people
and the support of their german sponsors
she's determined to press ahead with her
development projects
you